welcome to the first panel of the United
Nations study program tonight on the
MDGs the Millennium Development Goal
this panel is sponsored by the economic
and political development concentration
they are there I want to thank them for
their support in organizing the panel I
also want to extend a very warm welcome
to the first year student tonight and of
course to the second year I hope to see
you many of you during our retreat this
weekend on global governance and the
United Nations which is really
continuing the discussion that we are
going to have tonight on the MDGs 10
years ago exactly 10 years ago in
September 2000 and the millennium summit
we made a promise to the poorest of the
poor and we set very ambitious goals and
we wanted to reach the goals by 2015 so
we have five years left and the jaw the
world joined together in two thousand
and promised to fight poverty hunger
disease illiteracy and we promised that
we would reduce extreme poverty and hang
you by half in 2015 that children
everywhere could go and have primary
school and there would be no gender
impediment in education that the
maternal mortality would be reduced by
three quarter we promise to develop a
global partnership for development and
to push a reversal of hiv/aids and other
diseases like malaria
and much more so five years from the
goals where are we what have we achieved
what lessons have we learned in 10 years
what are the gaps can we keep the
promise can we uphold the dream we know
there have been problems we know there
have been huge challenges the effect of
climate change the financial crises the
food crises and we know that each time
it is always the bottom billion who take
the brunt next week more than 150 heads
of state and government foreign
ministers Kings private sector civil
society activists groups will come to
the United Nations are to summit on the
MDGs and they will announce new
initiatives they will rededicate
themselves to the goals of the MDGs but
can we make it what is it that we need
in the five years to come to do that we
haven't gone to reach that goal and to
translate the commitments into action to
discuss all this tonight we have a
number of speakers that I would like to
introduce to you candy yum killer is the
director general of uni do for those who
don't know what you nee do is doing it's
a specialized agency of the United
Nations who help countries attain
sustainable industrial development
kionda um Killa is the first director
general who comes from sub-sahara Africa
being from Sierra Leone and he knows a
lot about jobs and the lack of jobs in
his country and poverty and civil wars
he is a scholar he's chairing important
groups are the United Nations one is the
high-level group which advises the
secretary-general on energy and climate
climate change challenge challenges but
he is also chairing the interagency
mechanism known as the UN energy I want
to extend to him a very warm welcome I
think he's coming to see / for the first
time and he's coming right from the
airport from Vienna where he says
quarters is located to talk to you
tonight and he has in front of him a
huge week because he will be in the 53
events that the United Nations is going
to organize so thank you naf ecstatic is
the special envoy for hiv/aids in Asia
she has been appointed by Kofi Annan in
that position but was also appointed by
the current Secretary General Ban
ki-moon she was previously at the head
of unfpa and she has written extensively
about population issues she's a
formidable woman and she's a friend
thank you for coming nafeez
jomo sundaram with from Malaysia but
always think he's from Kenya because of
his name is a prominent economist he is
an assistant secretary-general at the
United Nations in the department of
economic development and social affairs
he is a leading scholar and expect on
political economy and development
especially in southern Asia he's an
outspoken intellectual he very often
does not agree with other people which
is good for us he has written
extensively he has come to see power
before and second year may remember him
in one of our panels and I want to
welcome him again Rebecca Greenspan has
not arrived and I will introduce her
when she arrives but maybe I should tell
you so that I don't interrupt the panel
she is the associate administrator of
undp which means she is the number two
of undp and it's the first time that
UNDP has at its head to women and that
is exciting Helen Clark and Rebecca are
really heading UNDP and they will tell
you a lot about the role of women in
development she's a scholar she has
worked a lot on the MDGs and she was the
vice prime minister of Costa Rica so she
will probably talk about also what do
the MDGs mean for middle countries last
but not least Bob Bob or who is an
assistant secretary-general for policy
coordination and strategic planning in
the office of the secretary journal he
before he came to the UN he was at
Harvard University he has worked in many
senior post in the US government he has
published extensively on the subject
that we are discussing tonight he's an
old colleague and I want to welcome him
as a matter of fact I will give the
floor to him first because Bob I would
like you to explain to us the political
context and the financial context in
which we are starting this discussion
next week at the UN we know that the
heads of state have are going to sign a
declaration or adapter declaration we
would like to know what are the new
initiatives they are going to propose
what is ahead of us next week how do you
see it what is the politics of the MDGs
right now so you have the flow thank you
very much Elizabeth and thank you for
not only the invitation but these days
at the UN we're in the business of
mobilization of leadership at the UN
around the subject I can see you've been
doing a little bit of mobilizing
yourself I love seeing a room on the
MDGs that has people sitting on the
windowsill so thank you to all of you
even if you don't have a seat this is an
extraordinary exercise in mobilizing
political will around subjects that even
in the best of times are ones that
people would prefer to look away from if
you look at what the MDGs are it's
basically a compact of minimal standards
of living and decency around the world
in areas that we generally don't do very
well in order to give you a context of
what's about to happen next week it's
probably worth just taking a very quick
trip back to 2000 when the the goals
grew out of the millennium summit which
was an attempt to look at the entire
agenda of the UN looking forward into
the new millennium what's interesting is
at the time the millennium declaration
was probably better known for a lot of
the elements that came in other areas of
the UN's competence on the peace and
security side human rights but if you
asked anyone today what the millennium
summit did or was about they would
answer the Millennium Development Goals
so the fact that development not only
came out of the pack became to lead
the pack in terms of what came out of
the future looking exercise it's an
interesting political story I won't get
into it but I think it's worth going
back to 2000 because one of the pieces
of what this exercise is next week is
taking stock of 10 hard years of work on
the Millennium Development Goals having
incorporated a lot of the lessons of
what's worked and not worked to achieve
these eight very important goals in all
parts of the world we have a short five
years left so what was already a tough
kind of sprint when you looked at it
over a 15-year time frame in a five year
time frame becomes almost unbearably
pressing the needs that have to be met
in five short years this exercise next
week is all about getting political
leaders not just to recommit themselves
and in this case it's actually bears
noting that the heads of state that
passed the original millennium
declaration if you look at the list with
a list that will be here next week there
may be no more I would guess than four
or five of those hundred and thirty
hundred and forty hundred and fifty
heads of state that we will see we're
actually in office back then so it's not
just a recommitment of Nations efforts
but it's actually a commitment by the
world's leaders today to a sprint to the
finish on these Millennium Development
Goals you have before you a range of
true experts on the Millennium
Development Goals so I don't want to dig
into the substance of the goals
themselves because I think the people in
front of you will do that best but I
would like to flag kind of the political
framework of this it's no surprise it's
no secret to anyone that this is the
worst possible time you could be trying
to raise money for poor people there
could not be a worse time there's not a
government that is not pleading poverty
there is not a company that's not
shedding people there is not a an actor
that we're trying to mobilize out there
that feels like they're on very stable
ground right now so
why would we be doing this is it just
the accident of the calendar that
somehow we said oh year 10 we got to do
something with five years left no it is
very much about taking this very hard
current climate and reminding the
leaders of the world that there will be
no recovery for the world and certainly
no sustainable recovery if the poorest
and the most disenfranchised people
around to the world are not dealt into
this recovery the tendency to want to
build on strengths and ride the strong
horses is palpable right now what we
have to remind everyone is that if we
have learned anything in this exercise
is that investing in the poorer and most
disenfranchised parts of our population
is the basis not just of prosperity and
morality if you will in the public
sphere but also of thing other goods
that government leaders want stability
security so this is the time to talk
about those who do not have what they
need to have it is the time to take
stock of what we've learned from 10
years of experience there is a very
varied tableau of what we've learned
about the goals and I think you'll hear
some of the dimensions of that tonight
from our other speakers but I said that
at this moment there is a strong
tendency to want to ride the strong
horses if there was one kind of trend in
discussions about the goals before the
crisis it was how well we were doing
that we've made so much progress if you
subtract China and India out of the
equation all of a sudden the numbers
don't look so good so the we don't want
to engage in a fictitious exercise here
that somehow we want to claim credit for
things that you know a couple countries
have done in fact we've seen progress in
many countries but if you take it in the
aggregate the numbers
if you're talking about the poorest
people of the world China and India move
mountains so if they're doing well the
aggregate looks good but we have to
resist the temptation to just ride the
strong horses we really have to go after
the hardest issues and the hardest
people to reach in the hardest places
and this is not just as a matter of
conviction it's a matter of practicality
I'll just give one example the slowest
moving of the MDGs has been the maternal
health goal if you had said if you tried
to pick an mdg that was maybe one of the
worst ones to move the slowest that
would probably be it when mothers die in
the birthing process it's not only an
incredible sad event and a waste of
human resources but the ripple effects
of the loss of mothers is tremendous
across all the goals in fact from all
the data we have when a mother dies her
children are ten times more likely to
die prematurely ten times more likely so
the ripple effects go into the millions
of people when the now 350,000 women a
year die needlessly in the process of
childbirth until recently we were saying
half a million but the new numbers have
come in that we have managed in recent
years to reduce maternal mortality from
500,000 needless deaths a year to 350
but far from patting ourselves on the
back that's exactly three hundred and
fifty thousand deaths too many but it is
not just women's health that we need to
take a mint there are other difficult
goals on sanitation in particular that
are not moving well again the ripple
effects and the cost of addressing
issues in the maternal and child health
space and on sanitation is incredibly
low so if you take kind of a political
approach to this as well as a preg
matic approach we not only have to go
after the lagging targets as a matter of
kind of moral responsibility but also
because of the ripple effects that those
cost-effective investments will have
across all the MDGs and across the
entire development paradigm one final
word about this exercise next week
Elizabeth mentioned the number of heads
of state for three days the fact that we
have leaders of the world focusing on
these questions for three days is really
quite remarkable the UN as you know is a
gathering place every year in the fall
and now virtually every year there is a
summit of one sort of another last year
climate change the year before that we
also looked at MDGs the year before that
we in fact have not 53 events next week
but we have 83 side events or Jomo is it
more now 83 I think during the mdg
summit this has become the gathering
place not just for speech making of
leaders it's for gathering all the
critical actors around the issues so if
you want to know what's going what the
state of the art is on what we're doing
on malaria what we the world they're
doing on malaria there's a side event on
women and children's health there's a
side of it you can go through individual
parts of the millennium development
goals there there of course we also have
a number of summits on Sudan and Somalia
on Myanmar so on the other side Pakistan
on the entire range of issues that are
burning or some of which are not burning
enough on the current agenda but to
think about as you are all here under
the aegis of the UN affairs program at
sepa another reason I like to see this
room full is that you happen to be in a
city now that really is the center of
the world for a few days here we're not
just the leaders of governments are
coming but the leaders of the corporate
sector the leaders of the nonprofit
sector and civil society the leaders of
philanthropy
the UN has become the place where we try
to broker the relationships that are
necessary to address really difficult
problems like the MDGs some of the most
exciting things that will happen next
week won't be from governments it will
be from some of the other actors that
are getting in and getting in for real
governments have to lead on this there
is a burden of leadership and there's no
question that having world leaders here
is the place to start but it's not the
sum total it's not just for having good
speeches and commitments it is about
doing and about the partnerships that
will come out of it and the concrete
work that will come out and in that
regard the kinds of new commitments will
see next week on the issue that i just
mentioned on women's and children's
health are going to be quite exciting so
at a time when it's hard for anyone to
get excited about the economic situation
in the world and certainly the economic
and social situation for the poorest and
most vulnerable we actually do have some
good news so one of the things that we
have to do is build momentum around what
we are succeeding on and what we are
starting to see promise in but at the
same time take aim at the gaps and the
things that we haven't been able to
achieve and in the hardest places where
we haven't been able to achieve it so
thank you for coming tonight we do
appreciate your interest in the UN more
broadly but especially in the subject of
the millennium development goals when
leaders said 10 years ago that this was
a 15 year project I had little
expectation that we'd be filling rooms a
decade later with people still talking
about the MDGs much less having rooms
full of heads of state talking about the
MDGs so thank you for coming and keep a
close eye on what happens next week it
should be rather interesting thank
thank you Bob um I think I'm going to
give the floor to what has been called
The Forgotten mdg and that is really
energy so i will give the floor to come
the young keller first and we will come
back to the issue of women's very soon
good evening thank you very much for
inviting me here you'll have to forgive
me I'm suffering from jetlag right now
eight and a half hours here and I have I
came straight here and then also I have
a problem with my voice but you know I
arrived here after two days of
participating in the Africa European
Union partnership on energy two days of
meetings almost thirty thirty five
ministers and commissioners on energy
but i'll talk about that a little later
spend more time on energy the Millennium
Development Goals I see a lot of people
criticizing them what they did for the
past ten years is give people in poor
countries particularly civil society a
set of simple indicators they can push
their leadership to achieve very simple
I see it in Nigeria worked in Nigeria
three years what I see it at home in my
country school children university
students and others can pick these up
understand them and mobilize around them
they've also forced literally I used to
be in government myself I was a minister
at one point very young at that time
these MDGs forced governments and
community leaders to focus on specific
actions they could take to move Social
Development so whatever the criticism
they've been a good accounting system
simple set of rules that people and
their governments can begin to work
against and they can be measured their
performance can be measured I tell you
everywhere these
reports now are put together not by the
UN they put together by the people in
the country we help but they put it
together themselves and you can see them
discussing that's the good news Bob also
mentioned another good news thanks to
India and China the numbers look good a
lot of progress was made when you begin
to decide regret and I'll focus more on
Africa then you see that we have a whole
lot to do some African countries did
well our colleagues in UNDP report for
example that simple interventions helped
countries like Ethiopia you know the
strategies that have worked include the
abolition of primary school fees leading
to a surge in enrollment in Ethiopia the
construction of health clinics in
Afghanistan which helped reduce on the
five child mortality and ganas
nationwide fertilizer subsidy also help
to increase food production you see
these are simple interventions that we
are taken up in different countries but
the MDGs enable them to do that I want
to talk more about the world that
changed in 10 years the MDGs were good
and yes the next week we sit and assess
what worked and what did not work what
more needs to be done in five years my
advocacy for the past five years and it
will continue I have always said we need
to look beyond the MDGs we need to look
beyond 2015 and in fact since 2008 the
impetus is even stronger now that we
look beyond 2015 the MDGs left some
things out growth for example when we
adopted MDGs in two thousand we wanted
to talk about the social sector good
it's worked it's going on we need to
complement that with growth we need also
to look at the countries that have done
well India and China moving almost 500
million people out of poverty in two
decades how did they do it no other
nation on earth has been able to achieve
that how do they how did they do it and
for me that's why I hope next to
for the leaders there'll be some
pragmatic discussion not dogma an
ideology because particularly for
Africans we need to be in a hurry we
need to be in a hurry in Africa at the
time that we were addressing the MDGs
and hoping that by 2015 would have
achieved them the world changed we had a
food and financial crisis and we have
what the biggest elephant in the room
climate change climate change and we you
some of you know the indicators if
climate change business as usual
continues agricultural production for
example in Africa will drop by 50% our
yields will just drop if we do not
accelerate wealth creation
diversification and trade in higher
value products Africa remains poor where
stock on commodities with stock on
commodities this is why for me I shifted
to talk more about the missing mdg
energy when we adopted the MDGs in two
thousand we didn't include much
discussions or indicators even for jobs
we did not include enough indicators on
growth the reality is for China India
and those that are doing well you need
to grow fast seven eight ten percent
that requires technology transfer
structural change in the economy from
just reliance on commodities to moving
into higher value products or doing what
some of the Asians did starting with
labor-intensive manufactures agriculture
alone will not do it even in China the
impact of rapid industrialization pulled
agricultural productivity up there was a
direct connection and correlation these
are issues we did not cover and so if
we're looking at the success cases the
world must be ready to talk about
structural change more trade we still
not finish the Doha round but we
promised poor countries that they can
trade their way out of poverty we still
have ad agricultural subsidies that are
suppressing growth in developing
countries it is not going to do it in
fact we see the declines I see my
colleague Ellen
back mentions here that although they
significant increase in aid we in fact
expect shortfalls of 17.7 billion
dollars since 2005 times are hard
difficult to raise money so we cannot
rely on it and in fact in Africa as
dambisa moyo is saying now young
generation African we cannot keep
relying on it and if we should not rely
on rate on it our economies must change
energy it's going to be crucial it is
the missing mdg and I'll just show you a
few slides here that I brought just to
hammer this and that's what I've been
doing for the UN focusing in the last 35
years to say we must look at it this is
the Financial Times article that was
there in 2008 on Uganda one of our
success cases that has done very well on
a number of the MDGs and hiv/aids the
when this article was written in 2018
financial times the population growth
rate in Uganda was three-point-three
percent the analysts estimate that in 27
years or 30 years the population of
Uganda will double for the children to
be a sport not as rich as poor as the
appearance that economy should double it
should double in 20 in 30 years you that
MDGs are not enough you got to do more
investments in infrastructure trade
opportunities technology transfer and
structural change movement into a higher
value product fortunately for Uganda
they discovered oil and the estimates is
their GDP is going to grow fast now
because they found a new natural capital
now spend a little bit of time next next
slide energy women spend many hours
collecting firewood they bring it home
probably after working on the farm this
is from Asia but the same story applies
in Africa and for some of the poor
countries a woman like that may even
have a child behind her back carrying
the child carrying wood after working on
pharm spending a lot of time collecting
fewer wood in addition also probably has
to go back and fetch water to cook we
have estimates from wh 0 and from
Berkeley University of Berkeley and
others that the use of biomass causes
indoor air pollution and we estimate
that every year about 1.5 to 1.6 million
people die from indoor air pollution
most of them women and children so the
time spent collecting fewer wood and the
social impacts negative social impacts
of deaths that work or energy access is
crucial if we're going to accelerate
movement on the MDGs this is why of the
many side events you hear some of them I
intended next week the 80-something side
events I have two of them myself some of
them are meant to say to the heads of
states and the government's hey the
other things you left out without them
nothing happens you cannot achieve the
MDGs energy is one of them just to give
you the gender aspect of the next next
slide the secretary-general set up a
group last year which I chair and we
brought in some chief executives of
various companies some involved in
energy systems like Statoil button far
these are big power generating companies
but also Suntech the largest solar pv
producer in the world the UN Foundation
academics and others to look at the
energy connection to the global
challenges around the world we set up
these two goals which will be launching
a campaigner achievement of universal
energy access to modern energy services
by 2030 the second one reducing global
energy intensity the by forty percent by
2030 why should we do this I give you
some numbers to show you why this is
significant here we have said that the
biggest challenge mankind faces today is
climate change
well eighty percent of the greenhouse
gases eighty percent of co2 comes from
energy related services power generation
transport heating buildings and so on
and a significant probably sixty four
percent of other greenhouse gases also
from energy systems if you have to fix
climate change you must have an energy
revolution you living in America you
hear obama talking about it every day so
i don't need to hammer that point for
you if you want to fix climate change
you must deal with energy yeah so that's
why we put an efficiency go but in poor
countries we also cut the trees to get
firewood and in the world today almost 3
billion people do not have access to
reliable energy supply 1.6 billion of
those have no access to electricity I
know this you know coming here today
reminded me when I landed here in the
United States in 1983 fresh from Africa
23 years old ambitious and I was I
landed I had an asian student who picked
me up at the airport and took the train
we came to 42nd Street I was there with
my white dashiki you know real african
dress and I was just amazed at the
buildings but Adam at one point I stood
there and thought of my university where
i had just graduated from we used to
study many times with candlelight we
used to walk two three kilometers down
the road to wash in the river come back
when because there's not enough energy
to pump the water to the dome eateries
we used to watch if there is no power
supply or food being cooked outside in
open-air pots so for me at that time i
was determined then to put energy on the
agenda unfortunately joining the UN i
was given the opportunity energy access
is going to be crucial if the MDGs are
going to be achieved there is no economy
that can grow without a reliable and
affordable supply of energy giving you
some of the numbers whether you want to
deal with climate change or you want to
remove
we must deal with with energy access
Ellen Clark from UNDP in her new
eight-point agenda maybe Holly will be
talking about that she believes it and
so I didn't have to convince her she's
from Asia she told me she said mr. um
Keller you don't have to convince me
about trade or energy or growth I'm from
Asia that's how we fought poverty my
conclusion is the following we must
think beyond MDGs beyond 2015 the
dynamics have changed the demographic
pressures are very serious Africa has
the worst indicators on various MDGs but
Africa is rich Africa needs to change
how it does business the next you slice
because you're you're Elizabeth asked me
to talk a little bit about governance
here energy governance in your courses
you better begin to talk about it
foreign policy is connected to oil and
gas and access to energy there is a mad
rush for energy resources next slide
this is West Africa the US Navy's
training West African Navy now to take
care of the the sea channels in the Gulf
of Guinea you know why when I was here
83 Reagan time we had a map of Africa
the Africa according to Ronald Reagan
Africa was Egypt and the rest that's not
the case today George Bush realized he
wanted to diversify fuel oil and gas
sources for the United States and for
many other reasons security and so on he
established the US command based in
Germany just for Africa they are
training people now to keep those lanes
open for many reasons but one of them is
energy resources some estimate that
maybe seventeen to twenty percent of
u.s. oil and gas may come from there
from Angola all the way but the
important thing is a number of our poor
countries identifying oil and gas
resources now ghana sara lee on
we are finding oil and gas and energy
resources in some of the poorest
countries in the world chat Mauritania
Niger sierra leone possibly liberia
question is energy security only for
rich countries will these countries be
like the Niger Delta 40 years or flaring
gasps my last slide will show you that a
picture from foreign policy that one
that's what we should avoid this is the
Niger Delta from foreign policy magazine
march this year gas flaring for 40 years
that's gas that should have been piped
into homes that's gas that should have
been used for power generation 150
million people in Nigeria less than
3,000 megawatts of power supply and that
economy cannot grow there will be chaos
question should these people supply oil
and gas only for you and me to be
comfortable with our SUVs and Mercedes
or do they have a right to have power
look at that the kids are playing soccer
around that gas flaring and their homes
do not have like you see the darkness at
the back go and Google this article
that's the kind of injustice you don't
need in this world so in the future we
know already that's why the sector
general is paying attention to energy
security for all universal access we
believe that if we don't have open
dialogue on energy systems and also be
committed to universal energy access
there will be additional global problems
the kinds we've not seen now I know
already in Europe there are a lot of
discussions about different pipelines so
is redefining political relationships in
Europe my message here is to achieve the
MDGs you need to power those economies
we must look at wealth creation no
nation has has reduced poverty and
become prosperous without structural
change without moving into higher value
products and manufacturing in the mdg
debate in two thousand we didn't want to
talk about that
Africa needs it Thank
my candy was telling me that he was
falling asleep just when we started the
panel well you certainly woke us up
that's for sure I don't think you have a
choice but giving the floor to undp at
this point they have inventions so much
we want to hear what undp is thinking
about the goals and what they are doing
and of course it will lead to the women
because I think they have really Helen
Clark and Rebecca have really emphasized
the role of women in development and are
convinced that we cannot reach the mdg
without women so here we are thank you
so much thank you and I'm sorry I was
late I'm sorry Bob but but they we were
talking with domo what did what they was
your introduction about so thank you so
much let me try to get some of the main
messages that we would like to live with
you today I think that it may the first
message we want to live with you is that
the MDGs are achievable and that a lot
has been done and so this is not the
moment to weaken the effort and I think
that we have to really make it happen
for the 40 people wear for which the
promise was done and there was like a
special like a contract that was signed
with the MDGs you know in a way the
international community said we will put
the resources if the country's put the
will the program's these strategies the
good governance for the resources be
used for the poor and they many of them
did it they they comply with that part
of the contract so the first thing that
we have to tell the international
community is that we cannot abandon them
now that they have done part of the deal
and that the effort has to continue has
to continue from the site of the
countries and has to continue on the
side of the international community so
this is like the the first thing I want
to leave the second is that we have to
recognize that the crisis did hit a the
poorest that were not responsible for
the crisis in a major way so some of the
setbacks come from the crisis if my
memory is is okay i think that they
according to the World Bank 62 more 62
million people it would have been on
poverty today if wasn't for the crisis
you know so the same with the crisis in
food the same with the crisis in oil and
the same with the crisis in in climate
change in the environment and what
happens in the in the poor countries
when the volatility of the economy and
with the volatility of environment or
climate related events is that the short
term poverty doesn't go away you know
you you really in those crisis have the
problem of converting like short-term
temporary poverty into structural
poverty precisely because families have
to take decisions during the crisis that
affect the whole life of the kids for
the rest of their lives if they go out
of school if there are undernourished
that will be sick there will be a
problem related to that that will live
with them forever so the problem with
the volatility of climate change or
climate related events or economic
crisis is precisely that maybe the the
rich will get out of the crisis and
forget about it by the poor will leave
the consequences of the crisis forever
so the problem of the volatility of
growth of economic
in environment related events is very
severe for the world and so there has to
be an understanding of how to preclude
those events for them to be able to have
a more stable growth in development a
that the third point that I want to live
with you is the problem of inequality
and it's something that we have called
the tyranny of averages and how to go
beyond the tyranny of average so you can
we can achieve the MDGs on average but
it may be well be that the most
vulnerable and the poorest of the poor
won't feel any improvement in their
lives because on average will be will be
ok with the MDGs but if you will look
and disaggregate what is happening
really there is a lot of inequalities
between countries and within countries
and regions so my third message is we
have to disaggregate the MDGs and we
have to see very clearly what is
happening to the rural populations where
we cannot get to them what is happening
with ethnic groups but that are excluded
what is happening with women in all the
MDGs what is happening to the black
populations where they are a minority
etc so the disaggregation of the MDGs is
a key point a for the future in my
fourth point and thank you so much for
referring for the eight points agenda is
that we have done this very important
study where we took 50 countries and
really looked in depth what has happened
to the MDGs and the whole purpose of
this exercise is to really see what
works what doesn't work in what are the
main bottlenecks and obstacles that we
need to look at to accelerate progress
towards 2015 for achieving the mdgs
and the things that we that came from
that a study is an eight-point agenda
that was referred by my colleague and I
will divide the conclusions into two
groups to go to be very quick with you
the first group is the things that we
know that we all know because we know a
lot about development and what works and
what doesn't that is study emphasized
because if we forget about that the MDGs
won't be achieved and the second group
is those that we have to reflect more
about them because they have not been
included or we know less about how to go
about those obstacles or there were a
little bit upset from the agenda in the
first group we have like for a
conclusions the first one is that a we
need to support control a development to
accelerate and sustained progress
development has to be led from within
from the countries from the leadership
from the government in partnership with
the private sector with civil society
but it cannot be imposed from outside so
the first thing to emphasize is the
importance of country led development
the second one that we all know also is
that the investment we made it we need
to target investments in health in
education in clean water and sanitation
and we know that so let me not expand
too much on it the third one is that we
need to invest in women and girls and
that's what was also said in the
introduction and that that's important
for all the MDGs not only for mdg 3 that
is on women and girls but for all the
MDGs that's important I will refer to
that in the second group again in a deep
from a different angle so those three
things we know we know what works so it
why are still the MDGs for example
relate
two women lagging behind if we know what
works we know that it's important for
all of them so we need to look deeper
into really the obstacles that are an
impediment for achieving the mdgs and
doing what should be done in these three
let me go to the second group that is
when I want to expand more and I think
that a it was referred to that a before
too the first one is how do we foster
inclusive economic growth and let me
really emphasize inclusive because we
know how to foster growth with exclusion
the problem is how to foster growth with
inclusion you know in many of the
countries of africa growth had happened
and very little has happened in terms of
fighting poverty so the real challenge
is to be able to foster inclusive growth
in one of the main aim problems with
inclusive growth is precisely the
neglect of the agricultural sector and
so to recover the importance of
agriculture and small farming for
inclusive growth especially in Africa
that you were talking about so
eloquently is a key point in the second
point is that it's not only important to
invest in women and girls the important
thing is to empower women and it's
different and let me leave this with you
two is different just to invest in women
and girls than to empower them to close
the gaps in education on in health is a
key point but to empower women
economically and politically it's really
the way to make it sustainable and
that's a central point of inclusive
economic
growth so empowerment political and
economic empowerment of women is at the
center and the same center of the agenda
and I hope that my colleague will talk
much more about that we can we can
create the clinics but women may not go
to new clinics if there are not empower
in certain cultures we can create the
opportunities but women need to be able
to take the decisions but themselves to
be able to take advantage of the
opportunities and we can create a the
conditions for growth but if women don't
have a voice so growth won't happen in
the same way and with the same rate that
we needed to happen so empowerment of
women and the agricultural sector are
key on this a on this agenda the fifth
point that I want to make is the one
that has already been made that is the
missing missing mdg that is energy and
it's absolutely true that we have to
distinguish between goals and means if
we will think that everything has to be
an mdg so you know we will end up with
an agenda of 1000 goals but the truth is
that we have to look also at the means
in energy is a key mean to achieve all
the MDGs let me just a say here that is
important to think not only on grid
energy but off-grid energy that is
precisely a key point on the for
agriculture and for rural development
and for local development so I know you
did that you made that point so
eloquently that I want a continued on
that we seek that's the seven a part of
the seven points of the agenda is the
resource mobilization and here as I said
before there is an important agenda in
terms of internal
resource mobilization so the physical
structures of the country's the tax have
to be looked at to be able to mobilize
the internal resources to achieve the
MDGs and the second part is the
international assistant for assistance
in turn a official development
assistance so they can match the funds
to be able to foster the development in
the poorest countries that don't have
enough resources alone to be able to
achieve the progress that is needed so
this is the eighth point agenda and we
know that that those eight points have
been known as I said for a long time is
not new most of them the only one the
only thing that I really want to stress
is that we cannot let it go now we
cannot we have to accelerate progress
and to strengthen the effort for all
these eight points that we are in our
hands to make happen to for the MDGs to
be achievable to be brought to next
week's gathering and for all the leaders
of the world to re-energize the
commitment to achieve the MDGs so a in
UNDP we have produced this international
assessment and the eight point agenda we
have created what we call an md g
acceleration framework that is a
methodology precisely to make the
Diagnostics what is happening and what
are the bottlenecks for the MDGs for
each of the MDGs to be achieved we have
implemented a pilot a stage in a ten
countries to understand if this can be
used as a general duel the results are
really impressive in the sense that they
can be it can be used for the diagnostic
to create the roadmap to understand what
are the
bottlenecks that are not only in the
minds of those that are in a narrow
maybe way looking at the mdg for example
if you look at maternal mortality
maternal mortality only from a health
perspective you may be losing many of
the issues that are really on the
obstacles that are really on the way for
achieving the decrease in maternal
mortality that we are looking for the
same happens in education the same
happens with the other MDGs so the
really the idea is to have this
framework to look at ed at it from the
bottle next are an impediment impediment
for a for a accelerating progress and in
an inter-agency a way be able with the
government to create the conditions the
roadmap the approaches the interventions
and the targeted interventions that will
allow us to get to 2015 within a greater
rate of success so the poor of the world
and have have looked at the MDGs not
like us not like targets or aspirations
they have looked at it in a very
concrete way that is a their daily lives
the improvement of their daily lives we
look at Adam maybe as indicators they
look at them as the way for survival in
to be able to provide a better life for
their families and their children I hope
the international community next week
with the secretary-general will really
hear them and will get up to the task
and reenergize the promise that we did
to millions all the millions of poor of
the world in two thousand so thank you
very much
Thank You Rebecca I would like to ask
Jomo to tell us if we can really reduce
poverty by half in five years and what
do we need to do so germer you have the
flow thank you very much Elizabeth or
this kind invitation and the presence of
all these wonderful people here tonight
is testimony to the distinction of my
colleagues here who my all of whom have
been leaders in very different ways and
bring a great deal to the discussion but
also this birth to your leadership in
revitalizing United Nation studies in at
ciba let me try to share with you some
thoughts on progress as far as MDGs are
concerned and I'll run through a number
of slides so because we have I'd like to
keep as much time open for discussion
after and we still have enough is to
listen to as well I think the first
thing to recognize as Rebecca is
correctly emphasize is that the MDGs are
achievable but it's also very important
to recognize that there are a number of
concerns about whether or not the MDGs
should be the central mobilizing a theme
around which we think about development
and I'll come back to this question
later x please now if we look at the
MDGs as as Bob and can they have
emphasized much of the progress on the
first goal of the MDGs which is to half
poverty and hunger is largely
attributable to China and and I'm not
even sure we're measuring the correct
things because when you think about what
has happened in China undoubtedly money
incomes have significantly increased but
you also know that public provisioning
for example health and to a lesser
extent education has suffered so how do
we measure this if we simply use a
manometric measure we get certain kinds
of
and this because this really raises the
question of how do we understand poverty
how do we measure poverty and whole
range of issues related to that as a
number of speakers have emphasized in
Africa there has been actually been a
significant increase in the number of
poor people next please now we have a
very curious situation where according
to the Rome agencies which work on
hunger issues most significantly FAO but
also the world food program as well as
ephod they had been reporting together
with the US Department of Agriculture
that hunger in the world has actually
increased over the last two decades yet
we are told according to the World
Bank's measure what is called
international comparison program that
poverty in the world has come down from
over half the world's population to
slightly over a quarter of the world's
population over the last over the period
from about nineteen ninety to the middle
of the past decade now this of course is
undoubtedly a significant achievement
but if the poverty line is defined as
what it takes to avoid being hungry we
obviously have a problem because one
measure suggests that more people are
hungry and the other measure suggest
that we less more a fewer people are
poor so something is wrong and this
becomes a very important challenge form
of measurement and how do we understand
poverty and how do we measure poverty
and this is why for example a few years
ago you may remember books were written
about the bottom billion and suchlike
and then suddenly when the new figures
came out two years ago we suddenly had a
figure jump from 1 billion to 1.4
billion and nobody could you know it's
it doesn't sell book books you not write
about a bottom 1.4 billion and and you
know so you know anyway obviously there
is a measurement problem next please now
one of the major thrust of the review of
the MDGs is really to begin to think
about what we may have missed
at the first thick okay and one of the
very important additions to the
discussion of the MDGs was the whole
question of employment and so in 2005
and the major review conference and Bob
had just come on board together and I
had just come on board as well one of
the major new additions one of the major
additional targets put on was the whole
question of employment and today we see
this when we see how significant this is
this is not simply something which is
significant for developing countries
where unemployment is not really an
option but we should think about
vulnerable employment informal
employment etc etc but we see this in
the developed countries where
unemployment has gone up to double
digits in many countries of the world
even in this country for example weird
up where unemployment is just below ten
percent we know that many people have
dropped out of looking for jobs and the
latest figures from the US Census Bureau
which came out today suggests that a
significant number significantly more
people are poor in the United States as
well next please now as far as mb g2 is
concerned progress on education this is
one of the areas where it appears that
we have had significant progress many
questions have been raised however
whether we are stuffing more children
into schools the same number of same
amount of resources in terms of teaching
resources and so on and so forth but
suddenly they are far more children
going into schools and very
significantly the gap the gender gap
between girls and boys has been reduced
somewhat not enough but there has been
significant progress next please as far
as gender equality on other fronts is
concerned we find that there's still a
great deal which witch is which which
needs to be done I don't want to go into
detail because we have heard
and we will hear from nafeesa as well
but Bob and and Rebecca have already
alluded to this in Kanye's well next
please now four or five and six deal
with health and this is where in a sense
the United Nations has kept the health
issue in life there are many people who
would like to talk about development in
the world without talking about health
issues and and and it is very I think
the one of the very important successes
of the MDGs has actually to keep the
health issues and very much alive now
there are many challenges many of which
have been addressed some of which have
been addressed reasonably successfully
work on hiv/aids for example there has
been significant progress as far as Cuba
as far as tuberculosis there has been
more modest progress malaria the
reporting is mixed but there has appears
to have been significant progress at
least in some parts of the world but
they are range of neglected tropical
diseases which continue to be very much
neglected not all of them former
President Carter for example has done a
great deal as far as guinea worm is
concerned but as far as chagas disease
from West Africa kundan knows this very
well Vinny a number of other diseases in
the equatorial zone we find that it has
been very different progress which has
been achieved there has been significant
progress in reducing under-five motel
mortality and so on and so forth but
still a great deal more needs to be done
next please now as far as their health
MDGs concern Bob made a very important
observation that there has been sick the
area where there has been leased
progress has been in the area of
maternal mortality and this of course
raises a whole range of issues the whole
question of gender and how we treat
women the whole question of of public
health because can you reduce maternal
mortality in isolation from public
health advances more generally and a
range of other issues now another
problem which might not seem to be such
a big problem is how do we measure
and many of us many people do not know
that in sub-saharan Africa forty-one
percent of sub-saharan African countries
have not had a census in three and a
half decades so this whole problem which
which Bob mentioned earlier the problem
of how do we measure the reductions in
maternal mortality part of the problem
is that the highest incidence of
maternal mortality is occurring in
countries where we don't even know how
many women there are how many women have
been dying and so on and so forth nafisa
dick when she was leading UNFPA was very
aware of this issue but unfortunately
there has been very little progress
because many people do not think for
example something is boring a statistics
matters now let me one of the Secretary
General's major initiatives in fact the
major initiative this year has precisely
been on maternal and child health and
this has been taken up by the g8 among
others and but there is really much more
work which needs to be done in this area
next please now environmental
sustainability I think this is one of
the areas where what we're criticisms
can correctly be made of the MDGs the
MDGs did not adequately appreciate the
challenges ahead we have also had set
targets which have not been met this
year for example the loss of
biodiversity is supposed to be stopped
that standard is unlikely to be met the
besides maternal mortality the other
area where there has been leased
progress has been the sanitation and as
a former President Mikhail Gorbachev
pointed out in editorial a few months
ago the number of people who died from
gastrointestinal diseases related to
poor sanitation exceeds the number of
people who have died from conflict
related violence in the post-war period
not something which grabs many headlines
but nonetheless very compelling we also
have a very very important success story
and that is the reduction of the
emission of CFCs which which affects the
the ozone layer and so on and this of
course raises a number of issues now
what does this suggest it suggests that
inclusive multilateralism can work that
even for a very difficult issue such as
the ozone layer it worked and of course
the challenges as far as climate change
our concern are even more more more
significant and much much greater but
nonetheless the success story of the
Montreal Protocol suggests to us that
they that it is very important to
continue to work within it within
inclusive multilateral frameworks to be
able to make significant progress on
methods which really count in the world
today next please now there are a whole
range of other questions as far as s
environment is concerned I'll just raise
one issue and that is the MDGs when
first formulated grossly underestimated
the number of slum dwellers in the world
it aimed to reduce to improve the
conditions over 100 million swamp slum
dwellers now any of you who have worked
on urban planning issues and urban
problems know that this is a gross
underestimate of the scale of the
problem so you know but it is very
important to recognize that we have made
mistakes so that we can improve our work
and this is why I think it is very
important to engage critically and be
open-minded about the about the issues
which we face and the challenges which
we face next please the other area mdg 8
is the subject of the is the whole is
really about international cooperation
and this is what the United Nations is
largely about how do we mobilize the
international community to work around
matters of common concern in this case
poverty in the whole range of other
mdgs and this is where there are range
of issues today the secretary-general
launched the mdg gap report this report
has come up this is the third year of
the publication of the report is it's
due to collaboration between the
secretary and the UNDP and this report
was launched this morning by the
secretary-general and already there have
been more than 300 news items all over
the world about this about this report
it basically identifies shortfalls in a
whole range of areas I want we don't
have time to go through them the whole
question of aid the whole question of
aid effectiveness eight fragmentation a
whole range of other issues next please
the question of the role of trade the
importance of food security aid for
trade issues the questions of trade
access next please and importance of
technology now contagion Keller is
co-chair of the initiative on climate on
technology in relation to the Bali
action plan as far as the as far as
climate change is concerned there are
whole range of issues there which are
which are quite complex but nonetheless
well it's only is precisely in
collaboration between universities such
as such as c / and the United Nations
and other internet inclusive
multilateral organizations that we will
be able to make progress next please now
these these are some listening some of
the criticisms which you have already
heard i'm sure all may hear about the
MDGs and so on and so forth but I thing
is Bob reminded us at the outset it has
precisely been because of the success in
the MDGs in terms of focusing attention
that I think that the MDGs in retrospect
after the after after a decade we can
say there has been a good that has
probably been the greater success if we
think of the MDGs as the tip as the
visible tip of the iceberg the iceberg a
very complex iceberg of development
and recognize that their whole range of
issues which are not necessarily
directly addressed through the mdgs
which also need to be addressed but this
particular focus on human welfare which
is the visible tip of the MDGs I do
think you will agree that suddenly the
MDGs has been able to capture the
imagination of millions of people in the
world and to be able to move move
resources and energies in order to try
to work towards what I think we will all
agree are very important and noble goals
thank you very much for attention thank
you to go in good diplomatic dinners the
most important ambassador speaks lust so
nafis you have the floor what do we do
about maternal mortality
thank you very much for inviting me here
today I think the fact that this is such
a full house is actually a tribute to
you Elizabeth because I've spoken here
on several occasions before and they've
been you know what quite a lot of
students but never this kind of interest
in your room in the UN subject you
introduced me as a formidable woman and
that reminded me a little bit about of
the International Conference on
population and development where some of
them remember that we had many issues
with the Holy See on sexual and
reproductive health and family planning
which I'm sure we all know about and at
the end of the conference the the head
of the Holy See delegation said to me
that I have told the Holy Father that
never do I want to lead a Holy See
delegation at which dr. saadya is anyway
interested because she is one of the
most formidable woman think and I have
ever met and I said I suppose that
coming from you is a compliment he said
he was not sure whether it was meant to
be anyway I think your title the MDGs
can we keep the promise obviously the
answer is yes if we want to I mean
that's so obvious but if we ask the
question will we keep the crop promise
really my answer would be probably not
regardless of all the wonderful words we
say and the high expectations that we
have and I really must say that also
there's a great deal of interest in the
MDGs the mdg and the goals have really
captured the imagination of all the
countries of the world I remember five
years ago going to so many conferences
especially in East Asia China Malaysia
Indonesia who were hysterical about the
fact that they might not achieve and
China in particular some of the MDG
goals but some of that urgency
seemed to decrease in the recent years
and we need to find a way to keep that
interest going and I think a lot of
suggestions have been made by everybody
here but i am not quite sure whether we
can capture that they've also been
suggestions that we should increase the
number of goals in sense to 10 and i
hear this you know in various meetings
that I be in attending that energy
should have been in mdg goal and of
course I always push sexual and
reproductive health and rights for women
because really if you look at gender
equality if you look at all the social
goals especially all the health goals
they're not going to be achieved unless
women are empowered and why are women
not empowered still with all the talk
that we have and all the interest and
all the support we talk about education
as the means but you know in many of our
country's girls education is not seen as
important their economic security and
that's what they are brainwashed into
thinking comes from being married and
from having a husband and therefore
their subservience do a male model is
inbuilt in our societies and this you
see very much in South Asia where you
see this very great preference for men
for boys also but also in Africa and to
some extent also in Latin America so I
think that while the global conferences
of the 1990s and I was still in the
United Nations in two thousand where
when we were discussing the Millennium
Development Goals and if all of you are
students and if you do your research you
will see that all of the goals that I in
the Millennium Development Goal were
first in fact quantified in the
International Conference on population
and development and then they were
repeated again in Beijing in the what
you call it the social summit and human
rights and else
etc but the key goal of the Cairo
conference was sexual and reproductive
health and rights for women and girls
and that goal was not accepted in two
thousand immune not I mean I'm telling
Bob I'm going to refer to him a little
bit babe and you know I fought hard for
it but there was a lot of political
reasons there was reluctance on the part
of governments who had come to the chiro
and the Beijing conference and had been
sort of forced into accepting this as a
goal but when it came to actual
implementation you heard all kinds of
excuses from governments you know really
girls and women cannot have this right
to make their own decisions about
fertility matters about if they should
marry when they should marry because you
know these things are so important and
we must oversee it we meaning you know
translate that into men so therefore
it's not surprising to me that mdg for
reducing maternal mortality has not
really reduced not made and we've been
saying the same figures in Cairo you
know the first assess the first studies
on maternal mortality we're done by
UNICEF wh 0 and UNFPA with funding from
UNFPA can consider that that was in
preparation for the icpd and that figure
came too far in over 500,000 we use that
figure forever and ever and every
women's conference every year gender
conference you know this figure is
recently a few months ago the Lancer did
a study and reported that maternal
mortality had declined a little bit not
the goal it's now you know all about
300,000 not 500,000 and there's a recent
report from the UN as well saying that
but you know this is the biggest
differential between developed and
developing countries is the level of
maternal mortality and it's it's
something that can be totally eliminated
almost with
you know ninety-nine percent of the
deaths can be prevented and if women are
to be out of poverty but if their role
is seeing as in service of how are they
empowered and how are they going to get
out of poverty because that is not in
their hands it's always in the hands of
some some some someone else and so I
think that we if we want to really
achieve our goals of poverty reduction
sharing inclusiveness all the right
words that every person everyone should
be you know have the opportunities the
possibility of making choices should
have their rights protected and access
to the means of economic empowerment
which is also a key and so on I mean I
did they agree with everybody but I
think they I haven't really thought
through how every single person in each
country is actually going to be enabled
to do that especially young girls whose
rights are preempted by their parents
society doesn't protect them you know
it's sort of the value in the cultural
system values that prevail in this
society that dictate what will happen to
girls that we are here and many of the
women i talk about south asia and africa
and developing countries is because our
parents did that for us so no girl
should have to have you know good
parents to get her right a right is a
right that has to be protected and given
and i think that that is something that
the Millennium Development Goals
discussion have to understand and I
really look at it I'm not sure that the
discussions will be open to these kinds
of suggestions even though as bob was
saying there are a lot of very exciting
things happening there strategies being
discussed and you know countries have in
fact done a lot of work but on this
issue of really enabling girls and women
to have the opportunity to make their
own choices there is not that much
progress there is now in included in
target five be achieved by 2015
universal access to reproductive health
but still no no mention of rights and I
think that is a key word right that has
to be protected remember they're still
over 200 million unintended or unwanted
pregnancies and if you reduce those or
eliminated those maternal mortality
would reduce by twenty to thirty percent
just like that by doing what actually
women want and are not enabled to do
also remember as I said earlier that in
the large part of the developing
countries the role of girls is
predetermined and free so I'm not sure
that that is going to change unless we
in the UN development system and others
really make that observation and this
makes me come to the point of the gender
entity as it was called for a long time
but a funny word and then now it's
called un women which is also a very
funny word but you know I mean it's like
an odd organization what is so all the
rest of the organizations are un men no
I hope not I mean I expected I you know
I wrote a paper about it once and I said
you know we have unifem which existed at
that time and there were large high
expectations from the UN fun for women
and the whole UN system except perhaps
for UNFPA and to some extent UNICEF said
that well you know this for women this
has been done by uniform and uniform at
like 75 100 million dollars and I wrote
in that paper that we have a small get
or now let's not get a large ghetto big
unless what we really need is for every
part of the system to really look at the
needs for women and men in every area to
really start to think about how will it
be done and what does it mean
resources must go and flow up from every
so unless this this UN Women does that I
don't think that it can be successful I
think a very eminent and I'm sure a very
powerful woman has been named as the
head of the UN Women but what her powers
are going to be how much support is
going to get and what authority she will
have in the event system that will
determine whether this entity can really
over say sea and ocean the rest of the
UN system to do to do what is needed on
the hope of full side I can see if that
a great deal of change in gender
relations much it off with the result of
unremitting work by women's
organizations gender-based violence has
come into very public prominence many
issues that we didn't talk about
publicly and now in the public domain
and then it's that in itself is very
much progress but I think it is really
time that some of these goals need to be
more pushed and for example you know we
have a special rapporteur and the UN for
rub what is it called for gender sexual
violence you know when they asked my
advice on names I said why looking for
women we should have some general
because these are all military people
doing this and why would you know
sticking this to a woman to do I mean
I'm not quite sure why these selections
are made and it's been decided these are
women's jobs and those are men's jobs
instead of looking at what is needed and
how it needed to be to be done so this
entity you and women I think has great
great potential but only if there is
committed leadership there is the
authority and they can oversee and do
the oversight of the entire UN system to
make sure that gender issues are
really address which means equality and
empowerment of women and that the key
areas in which women need empower
empowering starting from birth and
having choices is really addressed and I
think the Millennium Goals will be
succeed yes I think then we need strong
can it committed leadership that goes
without saying but I don't underestimate
the difficult the difficulties of the
task secondly the new entity will need a
remit that covers the entire six
spectrum of the United Nations operation
will the system allow that entity to
actually have that role third success
calls for the unremitting commitment of
each part of the UN family do women's
empowerment and gender equality in its
in its own particular area of operations
which I am Not sure that they do
creation of this new UN Women doesn't
relieve other agencies of their
responsibility to promote women's
empowerment and gender equality genuine
mainstreaming depends on the commitment
of the whole system on this as is the
wider aim of ending extreme poverty
which either we stand together or we
fall together I remember an a civil
society woman in a major conference a
major round table which was being you
know hosted by CNN and a vice president
go over speaking and there were a whole
space of and she shouted to somebody I
don't know she wasn't very happy with
the statement and she said uuu if you
don't help us to relieve I'd get out of
poverty you are going to be doomed to
share it with us we are one world and I
think we need to remember that thang
I want to thank all our speakers for
their illuminating presentations and
sometimes thought-provoking I think you
are dying to take the floor so I should
give the floor to students you must have
a lot of questions we will take three
questions at a time and please I will
not accept any student who makes another
presentation now it has to be a short
question so I will interrupt me very
rudely if you are starting to tell us
about you know your life or whatever it
is just give us your name and ask your
question and if poss possibly tell us
which speaker you are asking your
question too so just go to the
microphone and let's start the dialogue
so to speak okay you I have the film can
you hear me okay hi my name is cat away
and I had a question for the whole panel
thank you for all all for being here I
basically had a question referring to
agriculture and some of the arguments
I've heard just pushing towards trade
preferences that expand the aggregate to
the agricultural sector in in terms of
commodities especially in reference to
sub-saharan Africa and particularly to
countries that are considered to be the
least developed I've kind of heard some
of the feedback on what the prospects
for agriculture are in terms of the
millennium development goals but I'm
just wondering about some of the
arguments that are pushing for more
expansion in the trade sector what what
are your thoughts and what are some of
the challenges our feasibility you would
foresee in that sector question number
two this is for mr. you michela did I
say that right when you were talking
about growth in the importance of higher
value products manufacturing and a
various of the technology transfer
various other things that you said when
you look at countries that have been
effective
and countries that haven't what are what
are the things that prevent those
countries that haven't been effective
where the bottlenecks what's happening
that needs to stop happening what isn't
happening that needs to happen to
achieve that question number three thank
you all for being here it's a great
privilege my question is about the
emphasis on the global green economy it
seems as though an emphasis on that as a
means of achieving the or a few of the
mdg MPGs and the phantom MTG energy
would be achieved by focusing on the
green economy as wondering for example
focusing on sole solar stoves as a way
of alleviating indoor air pollution that
would both increase people's Health's
and would increase maternal health as
well I had the chance to question the
question so could you just comment on
what you think the promises of a global
green economy okay shall we take three
questions uh do you want to start on the
issue of growth last one is easier
we are looking at new green technologies
begins enhancing particularly energy
access some of the recommendations with
the report we launched for the Secretary
General on people this year yeah access
in rural communities using some of these
new green technologies on the 21st of
this month i think that's next tuesday
hillary clinton will be launching a
global initiative on cook stoves we're
looking at solar solar stoves and others
as well but she has made a solid pledge
of funds it will be done together with
the UN foundation and or the UNDP you
need oh and several other UN agencies
we're hoping to leverage more resources
but there's quite a bit of effort now to
spread these green technologies
secretary Chu just had a meeting in July
what we called it a first clean energy
ministerial meeting he invited the 24
countries that account for about eighty
percent of global energy demand to look
at what is available what they can do to
deploy some of these ready green
technologies to developing countries to
enhance energy access bottlenecks and
barriers there many there are many
bottlenecks and barriers for whether
technology transfer or achieving growth
for some countries serious governance
problems in Africa we've had quite a bit
of challenges on with stability civil
wars but also some some problems around
the world on corruption corruption is a
big hindrance to development and growth
when you have bad governance a lot of
what we've said about giving ownership
to the people and so on all of that goes
by the wayside so good governance good
leadership is important I think one of
the other serious problems that's why
again as we look at Millennium
Development Goals we have to look at
also how we do international development
cooperation there are some instruments
that we used in the early in the 90s but
particularly the first five years of the
Millennium Development Goals the
so-called poverty reduction strategies
we had dictated meaning the
International Development Community
particularly bilateral donors what
should go into the poverty reduction
strategies well when we did a quick
analysis a few years ago of the first
generation of poverty reduction strategy
papers of 40 of them were reviewed only
eight mention trade and only three
treated trade seriously at a time we're
talking about radio way out of poverty
so some of the instruments that we've
also introduced to developing countries
have not really addressed the ambition
and when you look at some of the Asian
countries that I've done the transition
they've taken some advice but a lot of
the solutions have been home grown so
having good governance having a clear
vision and not again short term
strategies strategies that look 10 20
years determined and sustained effort to
implement those are important I think
those were the ones for me is very
briefly a number people waiting as far
as traders concern I think what the the
right after 911 there was an agreement
to resume trade negotiations remember
that before that the Seattle inter-
inter-ministerial had resulted in in
chaos there were two there were there
demonstrators on the streets and also
within the conference hall ministers
especially from developing countries
especially from Africa walked up
the situation changed because of
international solidarity following 911
what we have however is a situation
where simple conclusion of the what is
on offer right now is not going to be
very developmental so the promise was of
a developmental ground but there is very
little which is a truly of a
developmental content last year you need
to publish the industrial report
industrial development report which was
very important because among the people
who co-authored that report were people
who had previously taken positions
opposing that that that kind of position
so you find that that that there is now
recognition that simple trade
liberalisation is not necessarily
developmental especially for countries
which have very little productive
capacities so right now the the thinking
is much more on giving on ensuring that
productive capacities built up this is
not just for industry it's also true for
agriculture the former president of
Madagascar pointed out that in 1980s
Africa was a net food exporter by the
this decade this past decade neff Africa
is a huge net food importer and so this
situation cannot be radically over a
change simply by straightforward trade
liberalization we need a much more
flexible international trade regime to
ensure that it is enabling for
development yes nothing I just wanted to
add something here one is this the whole
notion of ownership which is a concept
that's been pushed in the UN for many
many years and you know the program must
be owned by the country but of course
that it happens in in theory only not in
practice and the second issue is
accountability who's accountable I mean
we talked a lot and quite rightly about
corruption and poor governance etc
in our countries but also the lack of
accountability for the donors when they
press their programs which you were
alluding to is 0 for the World Bank for
example there is zero when you know you
have crises in countries because they
followed diligently what the World Bank
or the IMF has prescribed and it results
in chaos there is no accountability and
in Mexico remember we were looking at
the financing for development and one of
the issues was this accountability issue
mdg 8 was meant to be that partnership
but that is totally not happened and we
don't talk that much about it except in
terms of resources but there is also the
issue of accountability and policy
advice and I think the whole notion
should be partnership when which boats
have equal saved I'm not sure that
developing countries should have total
ownership when they don't actually know
what they want to own they don't really
have strategies and policies but also
them the donor countries really reflect
their own needs often in the policies
they recommend and then there is no
independent adjudicator for this issue I
mean it's it's really a big issue and
the UN used to be in the economic area
but it's no longer that and don't have
that role so there is no independent but
you know person that can mediate on
these issues this I just wanted to tell
you that my students here will have
heard me saying that the UN is not a
world government no and don't forget
this and don't confuse global governance
with global government the UN is not a
global government so how do you make
anybody accountable when your masters
are 192 member states and they dictate
the things don't forget this this issue
of accountability also comes with a
Security Council the Security Council is
accountable to no one so if we don't
miss if we miss the goals who is a
multiple is there any kind of
accountability here and this is a very
important point I just wanted to mention
it because nobody can educate on this
this is it okay I wanted to take also
the question on agriculture because the
trade part I think that Romo has done it
beautifully but let me say that they we
have to remember that for two decades
agriculture was not important in terms
of the agenda and the support from the
international system and the program
fact the culture is the problem of the
small farmers it's not the big
agriculture we are talking about is the
problem of the small farmer and there
are four things that were were really
weakened do it during a long period of
time one is the importance of the public
goods and the production of the public
goods for the rural development the
second one is that subsidies became a
bad word and we know now that without
subsidies for fertilizer and seeds small
farmers cannot make it and so we are
revisiting again many of the things that
we knew before but that were forgotten
for for two decades and a in in the
agenda I think that is very important to
remember this because with the food
price a prices in this was again discuss
a lot in suddenly the food prices prices
went away and so again the agriculture
and small farmers agenda can be
forgotten by the international world so
I just want you to keep us accountable
for not forgetting the agriculture small
farmers agenda that is so crucial for
development in the poorest countries and
to fight poverty three more questions
good evening my question is related to
the involvement of the private sector so
we know that there are companies out
there which earned more than the GDP of
certain countries I used to work with
the global logistics company whose
sustainability strategy was centered
around the UN MDGs and they had
fantastic programs in climate protection
disaster response etc so we know that
the resources are there the willingness
is there what can we do to really
harness the potential of these companies
and how can we keep them accountable
my name is Peter Burgess I'm an old
student I'm still learning stuff not
affiliated with the Columbia then I'd
like to make the quick point that
everything that's been said tonight has
been absolutely excellent but the UN is
by global standards today a tiny
organization they policies that are
being put out by the UN are really
pretty damn good but their policies that
are being put out by the other economic
powers on this planet are unbelievably
bad and I would like to see what you
have to say about a complete rethink
about how the you know wall street if
you will it's all about corporate profit
all about stock market prices all about
growth it is never about things that
matter really to our future quality of
life and I was so pleased when Jomo
talked about rethinking the how you
measure value because until we start
doing that I think we're we're heading
down a terribly difficult track thank
you for organizing this is thank you the
real question is if it's a question hi
my name is Jason Smith um have a
question for dr. um Killa um just kind
of curious in terms of opinion on the
so-called resource curse is it do what
you see if it even exists but would you
see its internal governance or this sort
of international structure you were
discussing where is it where is it
happening and and how do you kind of
transfer resource wealth into
development in any given country someday
just to wake you up
hey was that I did an interview with the
Kennedy School which was just published
checking serra leo and the resource
cost it situation now on that
particularly for Africa we need to
Africans need to take very seriously
because as I mentioned just in the case
of energy what is happening in for all
kinds of minerals Colton power wonderful
mobile phones I give a microcosm of the
manner of a union our neighborhood
Liberia has one of the largest deposits
of iron ore Sarah Leon we just
discovered our own now among the top ten
in the last six seven months Guinea is
sitting on thirty to forty percent of
the world's book air bauxite three of
the poorest countries among the five
poorest have three of the most precious
minerals in the world in addition to
many other things and everybody is
coming in so in other parts of Africa
but the issue here is the European Union
has been able now to publish the
extractive industries transparency Act
we hope that all nations will take this
at least as one of the beginning
foundations for 44 as as if you will a
an international standard for when you
are transacting these kinds of mineral
deals with with governments when these
deals are made for minerals you don't
have the UN in the room we just come in
when there's a crisis you know 20 years
later when the poverty is deepened as
civil war were called in to fix it but
these are deals between big
conglomerates and small countries that
do not have capacity to negotiate
sometimes in a good number of cases some
of these are from countries that are
pushing for human rights
for me today for Africa if i take my
country we have no business being boring
tenias bauxite now we discovered oil one
of the rich marine resources at titanium
and so on Airbus 380 requires titanium
but the deals that are being structured
now there's not enough transparency so
part of the problem the government's
themselves in the 21st century we can't
blame all this because the best
practices are known we've seen what
norwegians have done with the oil
resources so there is what we call the
Norwegian model how you avoid the Dutch
disease so that the newfound wealth does
not distort your your your price signals
and incentives within your economy we've
seen partly although it has some crisis
now but they do by model as well
whatever you say that small country the
group of emirates use their petroleum
resources to diversify the economy and
that's the childish for africa to look
around and really make deals that are
beneficial to their people and pair of
it starts with informing the people
that's why this transparency initiative
by the EU is important declaring
publicly what is the negotiations what
is going on and taking you to Parliament
but informing the people second
declaring the revenues the people should
know how much he saw there is a country
where a friend of mine was called back
to set up the petroleum accounting unit
it's not necessarily an African country
but this friend of mine told me that the
head of state when he was introduced a
now you will let me know how much we
really ship out of my country so the
it's similar to corruption we say there
is a giver there is a taker even with
the corruption money the money that
leaves Africa where the biggest exporter
of capital it goes somewhere the banks
see the money coming in so if we're
talking international standards and so
on I think that even those coming to do
the deal so we need good corporate
social responsibility we need clear
common standards
when we go into poor countries to source
the natural resources but at the end of
the day the onus is up is on those
countries that own these resources
because they are very many models Jomo's
country you know they're small Petronas
small oil company petrol nose is a
global player now but Malaysia cleverly
use some of their petroleum wealth to
support their agriculture to build
infrastructure and open up rural
communities to spur growth so I've given
you a very long answer the political
economy of the resource course is
complicated but there is this interview
I did using server Lyon as a case study
just a few few just lending last month
who wants to take the role of the
private sector how to seeing the private
sector I'd love to everything we talked
about tonight is a pipe dream without
the private sector but that's not to say
that we share the same interests as the
private sector there is no doubt that we
have to weave the private sector into
our work on every single one of the
issues we've discussed tonight but it is
not a simple equation if you're looking
at the agriculture and the nutrition
equation different sets of actors if
you're looking at the climate change and
maternal health equation different set
of actors but there are some promising
signs here let's just say we've been
very much in the corporate social
responsibility and philanthropic model
when we've talked about public-private
partnerships I would hear from most CEOs
they would say you un guys are you
government guys what you mean is you
want us to give you money that's not
what we do we make money we don't give
money now what's interesting is we are
moving into the era we're actually we're
getting out of strict philanthropy or
corporate social responsibility and
getting inside the business models of
companies yes they can make money but
can they do social good do public good
at the same time and the overlap of
those circles is actually quite large
we've we've probably
leveraged a tiny fraction of it just to
give you a couple examples last week I
was in London focused on getting
corporations large global corporations
to support women's and children's health
only about half of the companies in the
room actually had as their business
something related to health or let's see
the the big pharmaceutical companies if
you had a meeting on that subject five
years ago the only people in the room
you would have had were the
pharmaceutical companies now we had
global logistics companies to our
questioners background we had consumer
products companies and one of the CEOs
made a very interesting observation he
said for so many years we've only seen
people in developing countries as
consumers if we wanted to work with you
is because we wanted them to buy more of
what we sell we've slowly started to
figure out there are also producers and
that there's a virtuous cycle if we
actually help you reduce maternal and
child mortality that the products that
we sell and make actually are going to
benefit from it so we have to get inside
their business models and not treat them
as if they're donor agencies we
certainly should expect and use
philanthropic money that almost every
major corporation has a philanthropic
arm they can do good that way and we
should hold them to standards through
corporate social responsibility models
and the UN's Global Compact is exemplary
in this regard but it's getting inside
the business models using their day jobs
to help advance the public good and not
just their their philanthropic arms okay
listen we have to move on because we
will have to vacate the room and there
is a much better reason to leave it
there is wine and cheese waiting for you
so there are still lots of questions can
we make the questions show and the
answers short go ahead ok great i will
try my name is Janice I'm a second year
graduate student seba so two brief
questions one on a the political
leadership in order to achieve the goals
and one on
financing for development I was working
for millennium promise over the summer
the focal point for the US Congress on
dem disease so we basically briefed the
US Congress Committee on Foreign Affairs
first time on a question so how do ya so
it's it's the u.s. we we briefed them
first time five years before the 2015
for them on the end disease how do we
deal with the wrong people perhaps from
people in their own positions and the
second question about financing for
development in the last g8 summit in
Canada I remember David Cameron he goes
the only one pushing for to have a good
early commitment on the pledges own
development in fact in the final
declaration nothing was appeared finally
in the leading the declaration so my
question is do we expect the md's summit
in September to have a recommitment on
display system development okay next my
name is Alexandra luke and I alumnus of
cipa and my questions relates to the UN
coherence we know that the effectiveness
of progress and development depends on
how you different UN agencies will
cooperate and coordinate it among each
other's so what is your vision for this
question and most specific question to
both or on how you see the coordination
of efforts between multilateral
institutions and agencies who are
involved in international development
next hello my name is jamming my
question is for mr. yoncalla having
worked as a correspondent in West Africa
for quite a while my question actually
vore already answered half of my
question my question is how can we
ensure that the citizens in West Africa
have access or have autonomy all control
of their resources because from a past
work experience they don't come d
okay you think but don't go to sleep
let's hear the others maybe we can a lot
of questions they are sorry already we
should not see them who wants to do I
can take the Declaration what's going to
happen is it a real political commitment
on development Tom apparent to me oh
that's yours I will answer the UN
coherence with respect to the UN
coherence that is a very good question
just let me tell you that a lot has been
happening in terms of restructuring the
agencies to work together I won't refer
to that but I would refer to the
acceleration framework that is an
interagency effort to look at the MDGs
and have a roadmap for all the agencies
on the ground and the report just came
out it is called unlocking progress of
how we did that for it for the MDGs in
specific countries so really a lot is
happening we are doing much more
together it's not an easy task because
we are many agencies and many actors on
the ground but they really i think that
the UN has become much better more
coherent and much more doing together
with respect to each Monday to the
agency so so just to give that message
well debatable Bob quick word on the
political commitment side obviously
rhetorical commitments are not enough
but they are important to make sure that
you put people on record we are having a
serious debate about accountability and
it's it's getting much more real than it
used to be but you realize how real it's
getting when governments get up to the
to the gate and they pull back they
really don't want to have excessively
stringent excessively clear excessively
detailed accountability frameworks they
don't want an agency to be able to come
in and check the books and see what was
delivered and was a double counted
but the fact is that we're getting much
more specific on accountability in parts
of the mdg world I think we have to take
this incrementally if we can build
accountability models that work in some
areas we can maybe transfer them into
others I think the idea that we're going
to have one big macro accountability
framework and hold everyone accountable
top to bottom with every goal it's very
clear that many governments are just not
ready for that so we have to kind of
push it but we have to push it in a
smart way on the question of the UN
cooperation with multilateral
development agencies and in particular I
assume you mean the multilateral
Development Bank's I think here is there
there's an old story which is kind of UN
World Bank or multilateral Development
Bank competition we've actually figured
out in more and more areas ways that we
can collaborate using our relative
comparative advantages we also have
spectacular failures still what happened
in Haiti and I'm afraid Rebecca knows
this as well as probably anyone in the I
was going to say in the room probably in
the world in Haiti there was such a
natural potential collaboration between
the United Nations and the World Bank
and the inter-american Development Bank
it just didn't come together and I think
that's something that if we are to
actually address this range of issues we
need the stain power and the money that
the multilateral Development Bank's have
but we have presence on the ground we
deal with the peace and security issues
that if you you're not going to achieve
any of the MDGs if the country's at war
you're just not going to achieve them so
there are synergies that we have to
realize one final word you mentioned the
talking to the US Congress I've had the
dubious distinction of working on both
sides of the u.s. fence and trying to
work with my country's Congress for most
people at the UN it you just stay as far
away as possible from the US Congress
and that's where everyone's happy
unfortunately the bad habits of the u.s.
Congress have been learned by many many
governments now in many Parliament's
around the world that are all about
trying to get intrusive in the
management of global affairs in the UN
and micromanaging but are not ready to
put up the resources to make the global
goods available but I think here we have
to be on our game but we need everyone
to kind of talk about accountability we
want actually legislators in the game
because everything we're talking about
requires ongoing financing and you don't
get that just out of an executive arms
in most country you actually need to get
into the pockets of those who have the
money and make those decisions so as
hard as the US Congress is unfortunately
it's a school that we all need to learn
in because we're now doing that with
multiple multiple governments and it is
the wave of the future so as much as you
will hear super heated rhetoric out of
the US campaign and some of the people
who will come through the US elections
in November and believe me the UN will
be a target for many of those people who
come through those elections if it were
just a u.s. phenomenon I would rest a
little easier it won't be we're starting
to see this from various parts of the
world so we have to both defend
ourselves on the facts and defend
ourselves aggressively with a record
that stands scrutiny okay the
secretary-general used to say that the
UN is dsg and that means the scapegoat
it has always been there will always be
there so back to you my name is Layla
makati I'm an alumni from cipa my
question is actually regarding crisis
countries you mentioned Haiti mr. or or
Pakistan after the floods I'd like to
know what specific implement isms can be
implemented specifically in crisis
countries so that the progress of the
MDGs is not lost but carried forward
thank you my name is James I NIAMS Allah
from Uganda way to heaven and human
rights advocate Oh Columbia University
my question is about inclusion of people
with disability within the UN programs
650 million people worldwide are people
with disabilities and we are no longer
objects of charity but rice orders how
are the programs of a UN that you are
operating working towards inclusion of
people with disability within the
medinian moment goals and to this is a
recommendation but there is a need for
millennia moment goes disability
mentoring indicators for the next five
years to evaluate how various programs
but I tending towards achieving Medina
vehicles are including people with
disability who are the most vulnerable
when we talk about women with
disabilities they are the most
vulnerable by the batch of their
disability and batch of their being
women and same applies to the young
people I'll give an example I used to
walk two kilometres I have a disability
having disability to go to school during
my play money but there was a neighbor
of mine who needed the wheelchair shows
a young girl but she couldn't manage up
to now shall never gone to school that
confirms with the you with a UNICEF
report but ninety-eight percent of
children with disability are not going
to school so there is a need a special
focus for us to focus on the inclusion
of people with is a bit more expression
when we are reviewing this variant goes
okay my last question my last appeal is
I will use this opportunity to appeal to
all stakeholders including Columbia
University to make commitment towards
capacity building or people with
disabilities so what we see catalyzed
the achievement of Mary employment goals
thank you so much thank you we take all
the last questions go ahead good evening
my name is famine and the currency per
student and the human killer shot touch
briefly pun on the topic already but
basically as
also dependents are pretty pessimistic
pessimistic about achieving the
millennium development goals by 2015
what is the strategy for beyond 2015
basically Millennium Development Goals
two point oh so what is if there are
already plans on the way and how do
those plants look like hi Dirk neihardt
from united nations association in
berkeley california my question is can
you take this on the rope tow the people
that are geneva nairobi be in every
bubble will be to hear you global
leaders thank you last question you have
the last word my name is Julia Nicola
first year and my student just ended my
actual employment at Eun probably it's a
break my question is in the light of the
upcoming private sector forum at the UN
what's Thea your take on the financial
innovations would it take what's the
UN's row on the what are the innovations
for the financing for development the
mdg can bring in thank you okay thank
you what crisis country and mdg how can
we prevent UNDP
press this country yeah I let me be very
candid on on this one because there are
crisis countries in which really we are
we have the right programs in terms of
targeting the MDGs because there is a
minimum of a framework but really when
you don't have a minimum of a framework
we have to admit that the difficulties
that we are facing in terms for example
of security of the of putting people on
the ground etc are really huge so I
don't want to be here like
over-optimistic in the sense that there
are certain countries where we won't see
unless we tackle the root of the crisis
and the problem of the political
instability we won't see great advances
on the MDGs so our first target is
really to stabilize the country to be
able to build a dialogue within society
for that to be able to happen so that
will be the first target to be able to
go on on the MDGs it's not the MDGs in
themselves but to be able to direct abla
SH the rule of law a peaceful path for
development so the preconditions for the
MDGs will be set there are other crisis
countries where crisis is very focused
it's very targeted in several parts of
the country so really you can see in
some of them great advances for the MDGs
I and we have been seen improvement or a
on on them so in what I will a Pakistan
is not the same as say an armed conflict
ok so so we are not talking about the
same in Pakistan we have a crisis
because of a climate event that have
affected many many a 20 million people
and we have
the instruments there to be able to be
more helpful to try to preclude backlash
on the MDGs but it's different in the
countries where you have an open armed
conflict where the main target should be
to achieve to achieve peace and
stability so these are two totally
different ways of way of intervening
depending on the specific situation let
me just take then the problem of people
with disabilities and let me say that a
great thing has happened with the
convention for people for disabilities
and and that sisa this is a convention
that has been a approved in many of the
Congress of the world the problem we
have now is how you take the convention
into the legal frameworks and programs
of the country and we are precisely
discussing to be able to put together a
multi-donor trust fund to be able to
finance within the countries not only
the approval of the convention but the
coherence of the convention with the
framework of laws that don't consider
that at all or the the mainstreaming of
the program in the judicial systems for
example or in all what the UN death that
is how you mainstream the disability
problem in all the project and we are
precisely working in this second phase
the first phase was a face of advocacy
of making the convention known and
approved by the country's now the
problem is how you make that framework
that international forum coherent with
what is happening in the countries in
terms of the rule of law in of the legal
framework and we are precisely on that
stage so I along a long way to go in
that road but a very good start with the
Convention on disabilities that was
approved in
in the in the framework of the UN I
would like to conclude this panel by
asking each speaker to tell us in very
few words what they would like to see
next week if they were one thing they
would like to see happening among the 83
events and declaration the outcome
document what is it Bob what I want to
see is specific announcements of
concrete partnerships between partners
that cross the lines that are not just
governments with governments but
governments with the private sector with
NGOs because on the question of
accountability and delivery if you have
partnerships with people from other
sectors the pressure on you to actually
deliver is much greater because the
accountabilities for a company an NGO
and a government and an international
organization are very different so i
think the rubber will meet the road the
more concrete partnerships are formed
and announced around specific issues I
think we'll see a lot more delivery down
the road I'm going to say the same thing
again on sexual and reproductive health
and rights for girls and women but I
also agree very much with what Bob said
is the accountability for everybody
that's just not there and I think we
need to find a way not a global
governance you know
a sense for government but a global
governance system that is really is
accountable I mean we are a long way
from that I think we reaffirm ation of
their commitment and willingness to
finance these mud bog refer to a minimum
commitments that were made ten years ago
because some of us worried that other
emerging problems will shift attention
from these unfinished business we have
to solve this so we want a recommitment
and for sure selfishly I hope energy
becomes permanent my wish is probably is
almost suddenly not going to be realized
but at early last year the Secretary
General announced a call for a global
green new deal I believe we have a
number of problems which can be
addressed together we spoke earlier
about the food crisis the energy crisis
problems we have a problem of
development more generally and then to
compound it all we have the financial
crisis and we have what might be called
a Bretton Woods moment I think we have
lost it but we had the possibility of
the international community coming
together to address the challenges which
we face in the world together by if we
look back at the original new deal and
roosevelt in created basically about two
million jobs in a country which was
about one-third of the current size of
the united states two million jobs were
created through something called the
citizens citizens conservation corps and
it was you know it was about
infrastructure but it was also
about the environment national park
system and a whole range of other things
we had the opportunity to address the
climate problem by a major thrust in
producing much more renewable energy and
through a number of other creative
solutions dealing with the problems of
food agriculture and so on and so forth
all this could have been done if we if
we sense them the moment and we saw the
opportunity the alternatives
unfortunately are not promising I mean
if you think of what got out of got us
out of the of the depression it was
World War two surely there are
alternatives today to military
keynesianism and I wish the
international community had the kind of
confidence which was there the birth of
the UN bretton woods conference was the
united nations conference on monetary
and financial affairs even though the
united nations hadn't did not exist at
that time it was a statement of
commitment on the part of President
Roosevelt which I wish there was to be
in the international community which
would allow us to address all these
problems in together unfortunately my
wish is not going to be realize that you
have to dream of what you call it well
what I wish is not to lose the momentum
to sustain and accelerate progress and I
think that they that needs what my
colleagues have said brainer gize the
commitments in half a framework for
accountability and that's my wish thank
you very much i want to thank all the
speakers and all the students who have
patiently listened to them and i hope
you will keep relay in form of what is
going to happen next week at the United
Nations lots of press releases are going
to come out you could do nothing but
read the news I'm sure next week so
thank you again for coming all of you
you